you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme supermarkets
threatened to boycott
products from brazil over a
controversial law campaigners say
would lead to more deforestation in the
amazon rainforest
the cities that could be under water by
the end of the century
if global warming continues at its
current rate
and the world's largest coral reef
restoration project
regrowing hope off indonesia's coast
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
now retailers across europe say they'll
boycott products from brazil
if the country's senate passes a law
which campaigners claim
would accelerate deforestation
environmental groups believe the bill
will reward
land grabbers in the amazon rainforest
who occupy
properties illegally often clear-cutting
areas for agricultural use
the retailers say brazil's environmental
protections are increasingly inadequate
and the land bill risks even greater
threats to the amazon
but supporters of the law argue that
only by bringing properties
into the legal system can they be forced
to comply with deforestation laws
they say it would help small-scale
farmers to clarify
title deeds to land deforestation in
brazil surged to a 12-year high
between august 2019 and july 2020
with more than 11 000 square kilometers
of forest
destroyed that's an area seven times
larger than greater london
well with me is peter andrews head of
sustainability at the british retail
consortium
who say they support the boycott peter
andrews welcome to you
so what are these retailers demanding
and why
well simply to withdraw the bill that is
being proposed at the moment
uh this is the second time this bill has
been put forward to the brazilian
parliament
and uh at the time last year when it was
originally raised there was a big
backlash from
brazilian society brazilian businesses
as well as the international community
we are asking for that bill again to be
withdrawn
and that it's looked at very carefully
to make sure that the
amazon is protected while supporting the
economic development of people in the
country
well yeah and supporters of the bill
there say that it'll help
ensure compliance with deforestation law
so
realistically how likely is it that the
brazilian government will take notice
well i think what's happening here is a
big international demand for
for responsible practices is being
demonstrated i think you know it's not
just the uk there are other countries
that are are
keen that this measure does not come to
pass and actually
looking at what impact it could have on
climate emissions globally
and therefore businesses if this law
does come to pass will
consider seriously whether they can
continue to source from the country
and are these retailers responding to
pressure
from customers in this country and how
might customers be affected by a boycott
what do we import from brazil
well certainly we know that customers
don't want to be purchasing food that's
linked to any deforestation
and uh i think you know the retailers
want that the wider society wants that
uh the many businesses demonstrated on
the letter calling for action
uh highlights that this is a shared sort
of ambition
it won't um on a day-to-day sort of
basis have a
big impact on on our on the customers in
this country um
it tends to be the big products would be
sawyer so that comes into the animal
feeds uh such as for poultry
for for pigs and so on that then there's
in
for the meat production that we buy in
our supermarkets so
on a day-to-day basis it won't be a
significant change as as retailers will
consider sourcing from alternative areas
to ensure that they can continue to
provide
responsibly produced and sourced
products for their customers
peter andrews thank you let's take a
look now at some of the day's other
climate news and the un
says urgent action is needed to tackle
rising global hunger
at least 155 million people were
impacted by food crises
last year that's an increase of 20
million from 2019.
research shows extreme weather is one of
the largest causes of food shortages and
famine
around the world germany plans to reduce
its carbon emissions by an extra
10 to 65 percent by 2030.
under the new targets the country will
aim to reach net zero by 2045
five years earlier than previously
planned it comes after germany's
constitutional court ruled the
government must update its climate law
as it didn't give enough details on
cutting emissions beyond 2030.
[Applause]
lotus says it's built its last ever
sports car that's powered entirely by
petrol
the british car maker has unveiled the
emira which will be its final vehicle to
feature a traditional combustion engine
lotus's chief executive matt windall
says all future
models will be fully electric or hybrid
what we wanted to do was we've called it
our last hurrah really i suppose but it
was
it was a bridge for us to show new
technology and where we're going in the
future
and um it it's a technology jump for us
but we've we've said with our strategy
going forward that
electric is the future for us and we'll
be moving towards that before the end of
the decade
co-op says it will become the first
supermarket to sell fully
carbon neutral owned brand food and
drinks
it's part of a new 10-point climate plan
to achieve net-zero emissions by 2040.
other measures include price matching
its vegan own brand products with meat
equivalents
and cutting plastic packaging and
scientists have discovered an
interesting way to keep
sea birds safe bird life international
and the rspb
fitted 3d googly eyes onto boys
to create a floating scarecrow that
keeps birds away from areas of the sea
where they might get caught up in
fishing nets they found the number of
long-tailed ducks in estonian waters
dropped by 30
when the scarecrow was trialled
now sea levels around the world could
increase substantially
if the burning of fossil fuels is left
unchecked
that's the finding of a new report
published in the journal nature
for the first time all of the possible
scenarios from the paris agreement
pledge
to a complete abandonment of greenhouse
gas targets
have been modeled to predict how our
oceans might be affected
so this is how sea levels have risen
from 1880 to 2020.
since 1993 the melting of land ice
that's glaciers and ice sheets
has contributed to around half of this
rise
the antarctic ice sheet is the largest
land ice reservoir
and his ice loss is accelerating since
the early 2000s its mass has plummeted
losing almost 100 gigatons a year
and this is the effect it's had here's
what's expected to happen to global mean
sea levels if the world remains no more
than one and a half degrees
above pre-industrial levels and now look
at the level
if the world warmed by two degrees at
around 2070
it starts to jump but at three degrees
of warming the rate of loss increases
dramatically
at around 2060 and the report says this
change would be irreversible
and that would mean cities including
amsterdam new york shanghai as well as
the south of london
are at real risk of being underwater by
the end of the century
if no further defenses are put into
place
well dr tamsen edwards is a climate
scientist at king
college london and authored one of the
reports published today
dr edwards thanks for talking to us so
rising temperatures are prompting rising
sea levels in part because of melting
glaciers and ice sheets
what's the other reason well the main
other contribution to sea level rise
is the expansion of the oceans as they
warm and that's not something that
people necessarily
know that much about but the studies in
nature today were both
on the the land ice part of the
contribution
and what are the potential risks to
human society of rising sea levels
from the worst case scenario to the best
case scenario and could we potentially
adapt
well the numbers always seem um
confusing just like in temperatures we
think oh how much can a degree or two
matter
how much can a few centimeters or tens
of centimeters matter but it's
it really shifts the extremes um more
sea level rise will mean more coastal
flooding
around the world in some parts much
worse than others of course
um but we really tried to to highlight
the positive
in our study which was a a collaboration
of 84 scientists from 15 countries
predicting the glasses and ice sheets um
we could actually
halve their contribution to sea level
rise if we ramp up the ambition of our
pledges
from where we are sort of roughly today
to limit
global warming to one and a half degrees
so yes so what exactly
needs to be done to achieve that
well i mean our paper is not really
about the policies that go into place
that's the that's the concern of the
countries you know we have cop 26 coming
out people are uh the different nations
are updating their pledges
you know net zero targets they need to
have detailed plans in place about
exactly how they're going to go about
that we can't just say
net zero in 2050 we have to think about
what happens now and what happened next
year
and what happens the year after but the
point is here i think that sea level
is going to rise due to the warming of
the oceans and melting of ice
but we can limit the damage and we can
reduce the increase
in coastal flooding if we make those big
large-scale ambitious pleasures and put
them into practice
and if those pledges aren't made and
aren't achieved
who is most at risk which parts of the
world are most vulnerable
well our study was around the global sea
level picture so really kind of
how much of the ice is going into the
oceans and raising sea level so
you know how many centimeters of total
global sea level rise
will occur um but there are different
parts of the world
which will um be affected in different
ways depending on things like whether
the land is already sinking that you
know some areas are sinking more than
others
so it really varies regionally and
that's something that many scientists
are looking at
we'll see a lot more about that with the
new intergovernmental panel on climate
change report later this summer
dr thomson edwards thank you
now two years ago the world's largest
coral reef restoration project started
off the coast of sulawesi in
indonesia since then around 40 000
square meters of reef has been restored
increasing coral cover from 5 to 55
the reef can be seen on google earth and
has been regrown
to spell the word hope to drive
awareness of the ongoing threat of
climate change and show
how positive change can happen
[Applause]
coral reefs support around 25 of all
marine life although
they only occupy about one percent of
the ocean surface so
they're biodiversity mega hot spots
we've lost about 50 percent of them in
the last
two or three decades the biggest threat
actually is climate change
but there's lots of other factors that
cause their demise one in particular is
glass fishing that actually blows up the
entire fabric of the reef
which creates a desolate rubble feel
rather than those
sort of gray mobile rubble heads what
we're doing is bring corals back into
the ecosystem
and we do that by placing corals on
reef stars which these hexagonal
structures built on open community
that are interlinked and spread as a web
over these vast rubble fields
and you basically regrow the habitat
from the grinder and then the natural
sort of processes of recovery kick in
you get little fish come in middle side
fish big fish
the whole system starts to regenerate
[Music]
and that's all from us for today on the
show tomorrow why the science museum is
facing criticism
for its choice of sponsor for a climate
exhibition
we've got the full story here on the
daily climate show tomorrow
see you then